the nights are getting longer the
weather's getting colder and your family
is hitting you up about your plans for
the holidays so you know what that means
time to park yourself in front of the
Telly and get some gaming going here's
what's coming to Playstation Plus this
month and my recommendations for some
cozy games to play from the game catalog
before we get into what's joining the
classics and game catalogs a quick
reminder that there's still time to grab
your November monthly games which are
available if you're a PlayStation Plus
essential extra or premium Member First
up is neo2 for PlayStation 4 and neo2
remastered for PlayStation 5. travel to
a stylized version of Japan's early
sengoku period and take on the demons in
your path as a half human half Yokai
yourself you have a bevy of Supernatural
powers and of course your sword at your
disposal next up is heavenly bodies for
PS4 and PS5 take to space alone or with
a friend in Co-op to solve puzzles
assemble equipment and conduct vital
research in zero gravity rounding out
November's monthly games is the Lego
Harry Potter collection for PS4 which
covers all seven years of Harry and
Friends time at Hogwarts complete with
Oodles of adorable Lego charm for all
you PlayStation Plus extra and premium
members buckle up and prepare to not
leave your gaming space for the next
couple of months because there are some
big titles for you to get lost in coming
to the game catalog this month ready
yourself Dovahkiin Skyrim special
edition for PS4 and PS5 is roaring onto
the game catalog as the last Dragonborn
it's up to you to Traverse the grand
land of Skyrim and defeat the dragon
Alduin before he destroys the world
explore make allies get involved in a
civil war learn magic become a vampire
or do none of that and just build and
decorate a home for your family in
Skyrim the world is your oyster and it's
ripe to explore and experiment in Skyrim
was released 11 years ago but it still
has fun to play today as it was back
then just watch those arrows around your
knees alright if you feel like playing
games with your friends then take your
pick from three Tom Clancy games that
are joining the game catalog get your
Tactical caps on and work together in
Rainbow Six siege for PS4 and PS5 or
liberate Washington DC and combine high
octane action with RPG leveling in the
division 2 for PS4 in Ghost Recon
breakpoint for PS4 you play as an elite
spec ops soldier on the run from a rogue
team called the Wolves use your survival
smarts to escape the wolves and rescue
the civilians trapped on the island of
Aurora but there's more coming to game
catalog including one of my personal
favorites what remains of Edith Finch
playing as Edith you explore your old
Family Home and experience the final
moments of your family members as
Bittersweet moments that are as creative
as they are sentimental it's a beautiful
story of grief and family and I couldn't
recommend it more Kingdom Hearts 1.5 and
2.5 remix for PS4 is a collection of six
remastered Kingdom Hearts games so you
can experience the Epic Dark Seeker Saga
with Sora Donald and Goofy as well as
other Disney and Final Fantasy friends
Kingdom Hearts Final Mix is a remaster
of the 2002 PS2 classic and features
additional content from the Japanese
version of the game after creatures
known as the heartless invade his home a
boy named Sora must travel with his new
friends Donald and Goofy to stop other
worlds from being destroyed along the
way the gang travel to a host of Disney
World and joined forces with a lot of
iconic characters including some from
the Beloved Final Fantasy series 1.5 and
2.5 remix also includes Kingdom Hearts
rechain of memories a full remake of The
Game Boy Advance game that acts as a
sequel to Kingdom Hearts and 358 over
two days a collection of remastered
cutscenes from the DS game which follows
the character Roxas there's also the
sequel to the original game Kingdom
Hearts 2 Final Mix and Birth by Sleep
Final Mix the Beloved PSP prequel Game
featuring new keyblade Warriors Aqua
Ventus and Terra finally is recoded
which is once again a collection of
remastered cut scenes that'll help flesh
out the overall mythology a bit more
phew if you still haven't had your fill
there's also Kingdom Hearts HD 2.8 Final
Chapter prologue which includes an HD
remaster of Kingdom Hearts 3D Dream Drop
Distance where Sora and his friend Riku
must complete their Mark of Mastery
exams to become bona fide keyblade
Masters it also includes and bear with
me here Kingdom Hearts are 0.2 Birth by
Sleep a fragmentary passage a game that
while a mouthful to say Bridges the Gap
to Kingdom Hearts 3 by telling a new
story from the point of view of Aqua the
2.8 collection also includes Kingdom
Hearts Chi back cover another collection
of remastered cutscenes this time from
the browser game Kingdom Hearts Chi and
if that wasn't enough there's Kingdom
Hearts 3 for PS4 the Epic conclusion to
the Dark Seeker Saga in this game Sora
and his friends go up against their
toughest challenge yet as they embark on
a quest to end organization 13 and
master Zayn not once and for all once
you've played through all of those give
Kingdom Hearts Melody of memory for PS4
a world it's a rhythm Action Game
featuring all the best music from
throughout the series there are original
songs from Kingdom Hearts Disney
Classics and even a couple of Final
Fantasy tracks Melody of memory is the
perfect way to cap off an epic adventure
with Sora Donald and Goofy
in Oddworld soulstorm enhanced Edition
for PS4 and PS5 you play as Abe and
rescue your friends from imprisonment
once again soulstorm is a game inspired
by the original story but given a Fresh
coat of paint and some new gameplay
mechanics obtain new weapons and
upgrades for your sentient Starfighter
Forsaken and take the fight to the great
prophet himself in Chorus for PS4 and
PS5 also joining the catalog is Oni
chanbara origin Earth Defense Force
World brothers and Earth Defense Force
iron rain or for PS4 in the final game
coming to game catalog this month is the
gardens between for PS4 and PS5
manipulate time and solve puzzles while
experiencing a beautiful story about
friendship if you're a PlayStation Plus
premium member you also get access to
the classics catalog a bunch of great
games from past PlayStation generations
and this month's PlayStation is
continuing to celebrate 20 years of
Ratchet and Clank so five more PS3 games
from the series are joining the classics
catalog Ratchet and Clank Ratchet and
Clank going Commando Ratchet and Clank
up Your Arsenal Ratchet and Clank
deadlocked and Ratchet and Clank Future
tools of Destruction as I mentioned
earlier this is Peak gaming time and the
PlayStation game catalog has a bunch of
cozy games to download and play if
you're looking to get PS plus extra or
upgrade an existing membership to get in
on the action then check out
playstation.com for more info on the PS
plus Black Friday sale here are my five
favorite cozy games to play on game
catalog let's start with Spirit pharah a
game I haven't stopped thinking about
since I played it acting as a spirit
fairer you befriend lost spirits and
help them complete their unfinished
business so they can pass over to the
other side grab the tissues before you
play because it's a real tearjerker but
it's a beautiful game about grief love
and coming to terms with loss it also
balances light-hearted moments and a fun
management aspect as you upgrade your
fairy if you loved the hypnotic pull of
Journey and flower then check out abzu
in this underwater Adventure you dive
deep to explore the colorful seascapes
meet the creatures that lurk in the
shadows and explore the secrets lost at
the bottom of the ocean it's wonderfully
hypnotic and thanks to its beautiful
music and atmosphere it's a perfect game
to escape into lost words beyond the
page is a platformer with a difference
as it takes place inside the diary
entries of a girl named Izzy use the
words on the page to explore and even
change the environment to solve puzzles
as you undertake an emotional journey in
a gorgeous fantasy land taraway unfolded
from media molecule is a truly
Innovative game that uses your
PlayStation and your imagination in ways
you've never seen before explore a world
made of paper and help a messenger
deliver a message to well you you can
interact with the world in so many
different ways like using the touchpad
to draw Tearaway unfolded is a really
creative game packed with pure joy and I
still humid soundtrack to this day what
do you do when all the color in the
world has vanished grab your paintbrush
and put it back of course in chicory a
colorful tale it's up to you to use your
brush to solve puzzles explore and fill
the world with color there are wacky
characters to meet and customization
options Galore the only limit is your
artistic ability or even lack thereof
it's really fun to play in local co-op
with a friend on a cold day what are you
going to be playing on PlayStation Plus
this month let us know and make sure to
shout out your hidden gems and cozy
favorites below you can find me on
Twitter at Lucy James games and I'll see
you next month for your December games
foreign